he is Peter King here on the show how
are you Peter hey rich how are you where
wherever I found you where are you in
the NFL landscape today I'm in Berea
Ohio okay okay
we're we're out we're right at where as
of this conversation Baker Mayfield has
yet to throw an interception in training
camp practice Peter and and you Jackson
is mania here I thought it would be yet
to throw an incompletion so how how is
this playing out best you can tell so
far computer I don't know I just got
here about five minutes ago
okay um but I from what I heard over the
weekend there's quite a lot of
excitement I think the interesting thing
and the thing that to Jackson is going
to have to weigh obviously is when you
make that call and so like the other day
I was in Baltimore Joe Flacco's
absolutely reborn he's practicing great
he I think he always viewed training
camp as a time to get ready you know
he's never trying to be perfect in
training camp but this year he's trying
to be perfect in training camp and you
say you draft Lamar Jack's and I'll show
you what you got in me and so good for
him and good for good for that team but
I think it's basically the same thing
Tyrod Taylor so the first time in his
life somebody has handed him the keys to
a car that that that gift lasted about a
month and then they drafted Mayfield so
it seems like it's a matter of time so
I'm pretty sure Tyrod Taylor is going to
get the first snap on September 10th
there were 9th whatever it is but then
every one of those he's going to be
judged on he's going to be judged
harshly and he's gonna have to repel
Baker Mayfield and I just don't know how
long that'll last well I mean in your
football morning in America you you did
have a large chunk of space dedicated to
your chat with Joe Flacco who says that
John Harbaugh
told him on the
the night of the draft of Lamar Jackson
win football games and none of this
matters so that that that's all well and
good but Lamar Jackson has to be out
there on the field and as much as
they're instagramming out videos of
Lamar Jackson throwing the ball to Joe
Flacco I mean that's that's not what's
gonna lead Baltimore to the promised
land it's gonna be Jackson making plays
even though he says he still wants to be
a quarterback to me that's the story
coming out of the draft is how that is
actually all gonna be able to be put
into reality not just practice by the
Ravens I still I still don't know how
they're gonna be able to split that ball
up Peter
well I think what you have to do is you
look at the offensive coordinator there
it's Marty mornin Lake and you look at
what Marty Morgan Lake did when he was
in Philadelphia and the Eagles signed
Michael there in 2010 I think it was the
Eagles sign Michael Vick and they had to
find a way in that period of time to to
make Michael Vick a factor in those
games and so I think they'll do I'm not
saying the same thing it was funny I was
on the phone this weekend with somebody
who who knows Marty Martin white very
well and he just said that you know all
you have to do is get out the old
playbook to uh you know to the old
Philadelphia Eagles and you're basically
gonna see how they're gonna use Lamar
Jackson same kind of plays that they
used with Vic so I'll be interested to
see that I think we all will be but look
as far as I'm concerned the Baltimore
Ravens had become one of the most boring
teams in football and Borg also
translated to losing their 41 and 41 in
the last five years something had to be
done I think they made the right move I
love them I love the pic of Lamar
Jackson I do to it like I said I just I
just don't know how how they're gonna
you know figuratively skin that cat
Peter I mean and then you also were in
Philadelphia even though nobody wants to
say it really out loud
when she looks as if he didn't get hurt
right he looks like he's all the way
back you know we tried was you know you
think about it
this guy had more than an ACL and they
said that hey it's going to be at least
a nine-month rehabilitation process
which would put him very very close to
the first game of this season well we're
basically seven and a half months away
from surgery and I just I'm just telling
you there's nobody who would have been
able to tell I watched him for two hours
and 30 minutes or so on Saturday if you
didn't know he had had surgery there's
no way you've been able to tell that
this is the first time he'd been in pads
and eight months he look fantastic you
know he did sir two bad interceptions
but just the plays he made and the
torque he was able to put on his
formerly wounded knee that's what showed
me and told me what I'm watching that
that's all I was watching for I wasn't
looking to see how many passes he
completed or anything I was just looking
to see his physicality and he was good I
spent some time with him Saturday
afternoon 15 minutes or so and it was
surprised it was a little subdued but he
was absolutely unequivocally confident
in his ability to play play now and
certainly play in the opener but again
this will be the team doctors to the
Philadelphia Eagles who make this
decision Zach Ertz told me that look I
think we all know what we saw out there
we all know how good he looks but I mean
it's how big a deal really is it if Nick
Foles has to play early you know the
Eagles schedule after Atlanta is is
pretty good for them and at least the
first month of the season I wouldn't I
wouldn't I wouldn't be upset at all if
the doctors say
let's give carson wentz one more month
NBC Sports Peter King here on the Rich
Eisen show you also stopped by and saw
the Steelers and I don't think I've ever
said these words before it gluten-free
Big Ben
sugar-free bitter yeah how did the
Steelers the coolest thing rent survey
the coolest thing there was an air show
at the Arnold Palmer Regional Airport
right across the street from Steelers
candy in Latrobe so of course in Latrobe
it's the Arnold Palmer Regional Airport
and Ben had his wife and three very
young children with him and an hour
before practice I ran into him I'm one
of the far fields and he was there
sitting in the back of a cart with his
family watching this airshow and you
know it's something that I'm not drawing
any conclusions about anything other
than I just thought it was a cool very
Placid family scene with Ben
Roethlisberger before practice which was
really kind of fun he you know he was
sharp but when you're throwing to juju
Smith Schuster and Antonio Brown a lot
of people are gonna be sure I don't know
if you notice Ridge but how about this I
walk into camp and we can't be going to
and you're surprised by something hmm
how about tre griffey number 15 trying
to make the Pittsburgh Steelers as a
wide receiver yeah I know your school
misspoken groupies the caetna ken
griffey the first grandson and Kat
griffey son it was on Baseball Hall of
Fame weekend you chat up you know of
baseball royalty they're an Antonio
Brown advocating for Dez who had quite
the Twitter moment on Friday night and
you're in Berea where there is most of
the dead smoke and potentially assigning
what did you make of the Dez Bryant back
and forth Shawn Lee we're having to
respond both Jones's making comments
before and after what do you think Peter
I mean Dez Bryant leaving Dallas is not
getting before his time before he felt
it was his time is not going to be
pretty number one he's not going to take
it well and you know all you have to do
is observe how
boys over the years to know that des was
not a disruptive force on the on the
scale of say a teo but he's a disruptive
force sometimes Antonio Brown told me
flat-out look I love to have this guy on
my team we definitely could handle and
he would help us when super bowl and and
I don't think the Steelers have any any
intention of going after them
you know the Steelers are not looking to
add to their offensive payroll right now
you know they've already got enough
enough problems with what they're gonna
pay the running back and obviously what
they're paying their quarterback in the
Antonio Brown right now so I do not see
that being much of a chance there and
then let's get into role Quan Smith and
the Bears he's still not in camp over
what appears to be the new 2018 phrase I
think the 2016 in 2017 phrase was offset
language now we're talking about
forfeiture language where certain teams
are saying that they can claw back money
for any and all suspensions that keep
these players off the field including
potentially anything that has to do with
this new helmet rule that you were
talking to Philadelphia Eagles about I'm
sure this weekend when they got they got
a tutorial from league officials who
weren't even on the same page according
to the Eagles what do you I mean what is
happening here best you can tell Peter
and what's the way around it I you know
what I think the case is right here
right now is is very simple that that
they are right now trying to figure out
what they can and cannot find players
for under some of these new rules and
how much of that they're going to be
able to go recapture from somebody
signing bonus
honestly rich if I was real Quan Smith I
wouldn't sign that contract either I
would want it to be clarified I want the
language to be I would want it to be in
the contract right away that if I get if
I get fined or sister
because of this new helmet rule and you
can't take my money away for this rule
for something that clearly is a you know
an on-field suspension or would be an
on-field suspension but it wouldn't be
anything purposeful it's not a PE D it's
nothing like that so I totally support
real quant Smith and I do think the
league is going to come to the
conclusion that we have got to review
how exactly we we we are you know we're
basically saying that it you know then
the contract language just simply has to
be cleaned up Peter I know I'm seeing
you in a couple weeks here in studio
when you come out here to visit the Los
Angeles in Southern California out there
well have a good time look forward to it
safe travels safe travels
appreciate it there you go that's Peter
King at Peter underscore King that's his
new Twitter feed the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience